there's a hunger for this character to
come back i'm hungry
you know
it's been long enough you know something
else it's been too long enough you know
the return of obviously you and mcgregor
as obi-wan kenobi
[Music]
yeah give it to that nexium escapee
play some volleyball with that baby
[Laughter]
i love the art it looks great the
concept art is amazing oh
i mean more vader back together with
hayden
christensen
darth vader we couldn't tell the story
of obi-wan kenobi without addressing
anakin or vader
yes
oh wow
my man
enjoying it
i'm applauding for a for a clip on
disney plus hello there welcome back to
new rockstars obi-wan kenobi is coming
to disney plus on may 25th the 45th
anniversary of the release of the
original star wars film and the official
poster released showing ben kenobi
wandering tatooine holding a mysterious
lightsaber it's an anakin's probably but
could it also be qui-gons
cannot be
yes
will we do that every week for the show
i don't know if my neighbors are gonna
be okay with it i'm sorry i hope we do
i'm in an abandoned warehouse right now
and i just stirred up some rats well
those rats needed exercise that's right
uh well this is wookie leaks it's our
weekly reaction to the latest in star
wars i'm eric boss i'm here with tommy
beck told how are you doing tommy yeah
i'm doing good uh that's got me fired up
all over again i cannot wait may cannot
come soon enough for this uh you know i
know we have lots of other good nerd
stuff coming in between but if i could
i'd get that back to tank and just heal
up till may 24th
just get that goo off me choke me out
with black chrysanthe and then get me
back up for obi-wan kenobi i mean look i
just want to stew in
bacta for my whole life and just wake me
up for the good stuff you know
i wonder if bacter works like a cpap
machine like if you have sleep apnea off
the back that keeps the keeps the air
flowing yeah that's right that's all you
need that's all you need well uh so on
the star wars calendar ahead of us we
have obi-wan kenobi a series that i'm so
excited about we're so excited to talk
about it with you every week now this
show is going to be set 10 years after
obi-wan's epic duel with anakin on
mustafar and will be on subsequent exile
in revenge of the sith on tatooine but
nine years before a new hope now obi-wan
kenobi is going to take place during the
darkest days of the star wars history
that we know of really the height of the
empire the period where inquisitors were
hunting down the surviving jedi that we
saw in rebels but we were just seeing
the end days of those inquisitors now
we're seeing them just when they're
getting started baby uh now maul uh
around this time does still exist he's
still alive and he is uh he doesn't know
where obi-wan is he doesn't know that
obi-wan yet is on uh tatooine we see him
learn that in rebels uh but now he's
just kind of running the crimson dawn
he's bossing around the mother of
dragons herself kyra so he's still got
some uh time left on his timeline it's
really just a ripe era for storytelling
i gotta say
and we've been burying the lead here the
return of hayden christensen as darth
vader we're gonna see him in the mask
probably under the mask because why
would you bring in that handsome face
hayden
if not to show him do some acting are we
gonna see him like in the heads up
display of iron man or going to see some
flashbacks to some live-action
adventures from the clone wars era or
are we going to see him in his force
projecting projection visions of like
fighting off other jedi in another realm
it's an
i can't exciting
can't you're just getting me so fired up
over here i i i didn't blink for a
second and now it looks like i have
tears in my eyes
i'm just so excited about anakin it's
back to juice i swear
i'm not crying it's just basting on my
face
you light up tommy's blue dungeon and
it's just covered and back to juice when
you turn on that black light i didn't
even tell philip that i spent thirty
thousand dollars on a back the tank it's
just a giant saltwater aquarium that i
put some snorkeling gear in
but it works
now this show promises a rematch between
obi-wan and anakin that line from the
first star wars a prison so i've not
built since and we thought the sense was
referring to the battle on mustafar but
no no no my friends there is another
duel that's coming up in the show that
that's what darth vader was referring to
on the death star so uh but i think
what's uh another exciting buried lead
is the fact that there was this one
exchange from revenge of the sith
uh where yoda told obi-wan before they
both went into their exile saying an old
friend has learned the path to
immortality one who has returned from
the netherworlds of the force your old
master
qui-gon
how to communicate with him i will teach
you
my yoda's not great but i was trying to
do older aeroyoto when he still had some
gusto it was good that was that was a
yoda that didn't need any of those
testosterone pills that frank thomas
sells you on tv that was a yoda that was
just still getting rock hard every
morning
uh don't
you cut that out
[Laughter]
yoda yoda's just banging his way through
the galaxy in his little star cruiser
stop here i must twilight threesome i
must have man yoda just uh tripods his
way down the halls of the jedi temple
the other uh jedi are just like who is
that that's no walking stick but the
point is a qui-gon jin was promised to
uh to obi-wan to teach him how to become
a force ghost the reason obi-wan was
able to disappear the moment vader's
saber just slashed through him is
because of some extra uh after-school
tutoring he got from force ghost qui-gon
in this series has got to be the place
liam neeson comes back to finally
deliver on that promise so could obi-wan
still possess qui-gon's lightsaber that
kyber crystal could that be the training
we're gonna see on this show is is taken
mr taken himself gonna take our hearts
away i gotta help oh god i hope so too
he's got a very particular set of skills
among the path to immortality and i
can't wait to see it well before we
discuss that the special book of boba
fett latest obsession shirt is almost
sold out at epic heroshop.com previously
obsession shirts for no way home and
hawkeye are already sold out so you
gotta grab this bad boy before it
disappears into the sands attached to it
forever we were told that apparently we
didn't push the boba fett shirt hard
enough and when we were covering the
book of boba fett i thought we mentioned
it quite a bit but not every episode so
i'm gonna mention this till the day i
die please buy our boba fett hunter
shirt you hey hey you look you at home
you look at me right now
you buy a boba fett shirt but something
really bad is gonna happen to your
family
yeah
oh what's that bad thing gonna be no
we're not gonna kill that but
thanksgiving dinner we're all gathered
around i'm gonna open the window just to
crack and stick my booty hole right in
there yeah and lay the hottest part you
ever smelled and then i'm gonna close
the window and sneak away and you're not
gonna know who on the family who who did
it what's mine they're all gonna go to
each other and turn against each other
that's a boba fart
okay
that's a book of boba farts
that's a boba promise
[Laughter]
all right we've lost our minds we've
definitely lost the fans here it's a
slow news week in the galaxy
dude max rebo would blast some
thanksgiving farts that would knock out
a family on the floor with this weird
punched up hind legs that hole is wide
all right that's right and he'll drop
some explosion and that's going to be
the explosion he always sneaks away from
they're always caused by max rebo's
farts that's how he keeps getting away
he drops the fart the gas makes his way
to a lit flame and he's long gone at
that time
i'm just using his gas his gas is like
like the genies wisp in aladdin it's
just a blue
coiling
max rebro you're free
i can't wait to see the world
all right eric
i got a question for you baby
kenobi
whose lightsaber is in the kenobi poster
yes
great question well i can tell you
there's actually a second lightsaber
hidden in that poster obi-wan's
lightsaber appears in the letter i of
kenobi nice little easter egg they snuck
in there but of course referring to the
lightsaber that obi-wan is holding as he
walks the dune sea of tatooine that's an
interesting shape it has this pointy end
that many are comparing to the tip of
anakin's lightsaber which had that kind
of sloped edge to it um that was the one
of course that obi-wan grabbed from the
lava beach on mustafar after leaving
anakin for dead later tinkered with and
given to anakin's son luke in a new hope
it's just pretty hard to tell from this
distance and it's interesting that they
put it on the poster why would he have
it out like this if he's a jedi exile he
doesn't want people to even know he
changed his name to ben kenobi to avoid
you know being compared to his uh to the
famous jedi self but that lightsaber
could also belong to his old master
qui-gon jinn whom yoda ended revenge of
the sith by promising obi-wan that he
would teach how to commune with setting
up obi-wan's ability to return as a
force ghost and empire strikes back and
return the jedi as uh some a skill
taught to him by qui-gon who was the
jedi who rediscovered forced ghosting
after it was a skill lost after
millennia from jedi dogma he was the guy
who figured it out he was the guy who
brought it back to all these other jedi
the one who taught it to yoda as well in
his exile on dagobah either way we are
set up for some major reunions on this
series tommy a rematch between obi-wan
and darth vader
both men at the height of their powers
and potentially an appearance by liam
neeson as force ghost qui-gon and we've
also heard reports that the series will
show us a young luke skywalker age 10
and also potentially a young leia organa
what could be happening with these two
we know from uh some comics laura that
at one point young luke ran into a a
crate dragon
that there was a whole story that
obi-wan kind of protected him but where
was young princess leia at this time why
would she need protection um now
directing this series is going to be
debra chow who directed the the two
season one episodes of the mandalorian
chapter three the sin you remember that
one that's when mando goes back to
navarro uh hands over grogu but then
gets second thoughts and rescues him
with the help of the rest of the watch
where they had the iron man moment with
john favreau saluting them by the by the
razor crass and then chapter seven the
reckoning in which amando and grogu cara
dune and quill return navarro and uh
that's the episode that introduces the
concept of force healing to the star
wars universe just an interesting note
there also deborah chao cameoed in
mandalorian chapter six as a new
republic x-wing pilot sash ketter and
all of these episodes are being written
by joby harold who most recently wrote
zack snyder's army of the dead and the
reason i mentioned this tommy is it's
going to be the first star wars disney
plus series that we see including the
animated seasons that do not have dave
filoni listed among the executive
producers now that might change he is
still the darling of lucasfilm maybe
brought into consult even guest direct
but for now this series seems to be made
separate from the uh felony fabro team
that gave us everything else
will that matter though john favreau is
also the credited writer on all those
goofy episodes of boba fett that you
didn't like dave filoni produced all the
goofy episodes of clone wars that you
just pretend didn't happen uh
and you know aren't fans just that eager
to see ew and mcgregor hayden
christensen liam neeson again this time
with some better dialogue maybe that the
series can't really be screwed up yeah i
mean i think that they have such a huge
canvas with possibility that they can
paint on this season i do think it'll be
hard to screw up now i may eat my words
i may be sitting in this blue dungeon
crying real tears
after hours in my saltwater tank but i i
think that no i think that the potential
for
character development of beloved
characters that we as fans have never
thought we were gonna get to see more of
in in a live action setting it's just
too ripe
with possibility for it to be to be a
failure i mean i just
all of the conclusions we made
you know i i i think of mostly as
watching the the prequels as a kid and
then being like oh the next time we see
these characters is a new hope a movie
that can't you know doing the the mental
gymnastics of a movie that came out
20 something years prior to that it's
like no now now we are going to find out
what happened in between and although
the actors aren't the same people it's a
in in a lot of cases it's like these
characters did have lives in between i
mean instead of just being like a 17
year old thinking that obi-wan just sat
in a cave
you know for his like waiting for luke
skywalker to be ready it's like no maybe
he did have adventures and maybe he
acted as a like completely in the
shadows operative protecting you know
valuable uh rebellion assets like
princess leia and like luke and people
that he cared about you know not just
assets but people who genuinely cared
about i'm so excited i'm rambling that's
why that's how yes
hey that's what we do here man we were
born around blind man that's right but
but you know what i think the fact that
we have this promise of qui-gon the fact
that uh hayden christensen has been cast
on this show i know i keep coming back
to that that's always been the biggest
curiosity point because he could totally
do darth vader on the show and not and
not bring back hayden christensen at all
he's in the mask now you bring in james
earl jones just to do the voice again
we're good to go
but they want hayden christensen's face
in this show and i think that's a great
choice i love that they're doing that
give an opportunity for some redemption
for anyone who might still have mixed
feelings about the the prequels but also
it it sets up the promise that this
series is going to be mystic in ways
that we have not yet seen in star wars
live action we're going to go to some
dark visions territories the fact that
qui-gon comes from the nether regions of
the force that's just like a
front that we have not yet seen a live
action some of my favorite shots in the
book of boba fett was when he just had
that spirit journey with the nose lizard
taking him to the gaffy tree in the
middle of the dune sea i love when star
wars does that and i think there's an
opportunity to do that even more but in
a very uh dark nightmarish way
um i i wanna see uh obi-wan still have
this relationship with his former
student and his former best friend but
the two men are just connecting through
the force we kind of saw that in the
last jedi right with uh with ray and
with kylo ren using these force time
chats
they were having four skype dates this
is the way i like yeah pretty much
um i want to see like an early dirty
version of this yeah with these two uh
these two souls connecting oh yeah that
could be the battle that they have it's
just a battle of the minds and that's
the way you can truly have a
face-to-face battle uh
that's what luke did at the end he was
using the force projecting a force ghost
version of himself to fight kylo ren
right
on crait um like this could be an
opportunity to show like an early stage
version of that of these two uh these
two souls the the two human aspects of
them
and maybe in that in that projection
anakin is not or darth vader is not as
crippled you know what i mean it's not
as wounded
deformed maybe he's just the
last time obi-wan saw him fully intact
on mustafar maybe that is the yeah maybe
that is the version that we get and it
is just kind of uh
like a almost like the xavier magneto
chess games there's not physical
violence there's just mental games being
played yeah yeah and you know what i
want to see is like the moment of anakin
right before i have the high ground or
maybe right after the high ground before
the lava caught him like he's uh he's at
his uh fieriest rage at obi-wan that
look that he gave him that probably just
broke obi-wan's heart and when he was
most afraid of him
but also felt the worst because he knew
he knew he had the high ground in that
moment and he's like he's going to try
it he's going to try it and i'm going to
strike him down and it's going to suck
and i and i hate it like i hate that i
have to do this but i have to because
otherwise he's going to kill padme he's
going to kill that baby that's right so
i have to do this i'm going to lose a
part of myself when i do this and that's
the version that he would have to fight
you know that's what i want i want them
to return to that moment um
i think that's what we're going to see
uh but uh the fact that he has a
lightsaber out right now makes me wonder
is this a moment where like he was about
to give that lightsaber to 10 year old
luke oh yeah we're going to see some
episode where he's like now do i give it
to him now right he's not ready yet he's
not right yeah
maybe maybe he is about to then he sees
luke do something so impulsive it
reminds him of anakin and he's like ah i
gotta make sure
that the darkness is not fully there yet
you know yeah oh i like that idea uh uh
you know
luke uh blasting a womp rat or something
yeah we all know he knows how to do it
and uh and it's ready to correct
that's right that's right not much
bigger than two meters uh yeah i think
that's fascinating what what dark signs
are we gonna see in luke 10 year old
luke in this series uh that made obi-wan
stay away from him for so long
interesting thoughts i mean we're going
to be talking about obi-wan a lot over
the next coming weeks but we got some
other major star wars news this week
that spider-man no way home director
john watts is going to be directing a
new star wars title we're going to talk
about that more in a second but first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode starting with
masterclass now with masterclass you can
learn from the world's best minds
anytime anywhere at your own pace you
can learn poker from phil ivey learn
drumming from ringo starr learn
basketball from steph curry with over
100 classes from a range of world-class
instructors that thing you've always
wanted to do is closer than you think
here at new rockstars we are huge fans
of the writing and filmmaking classes
they've got classes from big directors
writers actors they even have classes
with both danny elfman and hans zimmer
two absolute movie scorer titans the
classes from sandman creator neil gaiman
on storytelling is great he covers
everything from how to discover your
writing voice to how to overcome
writer's block the classes are really
well produced and you can watch them on
your computer smart tv or any other
device where you stream there are actual
projects for you to do so the learning
is immersive and more active we highly
recommend you check it out get unlimited
classes to every master class and for
the new rockstars audience you can get
15 off an annual membership just go to
masterclass.com
wookie that's wookie with two e's we
also want to thank blue true for
sponsoring this episode now we are
pretty confident in our theories here on
wikileaks and confidence can take you
pretty far in life and in the bedroom
and that's where bluetooth comes in
bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can plan ahead or be ready
for whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple you signed by
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line to pharmacy blue shoes
tablets are made in the usa and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discreet package so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform bluetooth can help and
we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code new rockstars at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code new
rockstars to receive your first month
for free visit bluetooth for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the show and we lastly want to thank a
wondery badlands for sponsoring this
episode most of us have accepted that
celebrities and stars just live by a
different set of rules at times they
even seem to get away with murder and
some literally have well on the badlands
podcast you can listen to the real life
stories of a-listers whose crimes and
career lows are as unbelievable as some
of their film's plot twists this season
they look at heath ledger's spiral in
the darkness in his final days ah i
remember that time uh it's a fascinating
story they'll also cover brittany
murphy's mysterious unusual death and
jack nicholson's proclivity to fits of
rage time to spill the tea on jack uh
they also get to that fun backstory of
america's dad tim allen the man who
played santa claus and how he got his
comedy start in a minnesota prison the
guy tried to fly
from a kalamazoo airport with
over a pound and a half of cocaine what
was he thinking
doesn't matter what it wasn't the guy
was just trying to get to infinity and
beyond in his brain i'll tell you what
i'll tell you what makes you think you
can fly from a kalamazoo airport with a
pound and a half of cocaine a pound and
a half of cocaine inside of you that is
the confidence that you need
to be like i can do this i can do it
come on let's go let's go let's go well
for all that and more listen to badlands
a true crime podcast that dives deep
into the stories of the famous at their
most infamous this show is that perfect
mix of entertainment history and true
crime that can scratch both of those
itches if you're fans of that genre
you're going to love badlands as much as
we do get new episodes every wednesday
wherever you get your podcasts or binge
all of season 3 ad free right now only
on amazon music all right tommy what are
we talking about next well eric as you
teased before you peaked to my interest
and i simply must know what star wars
series is john watts directing
okay so this comes a report from a
discussing film that said that john
watts director of spider-man no way home
all three of the mcu spider-man movies
we'll be directing at least one episode
of the upcoming star wars series that
apparently is operating under the
working title of grammar rodeo now john
fabro is reportedly attached to
executive produce
this of course following john favreau uh
being the writer and executive producer
on both the mandalorian and the book of
bible pet it's just currently unknown
who's gonna be writing this new series
uh but you know we're gonna find out
more as it nears production and it's
currently suggested to start shooting
this summer
um and uh the outlet cinelinx first
reported on this series describing it as
stranger things in space with a story
that focuses on a younger generation of
heroes during the high republic era
now uh another series that we know of
the acolyte uh is coming to disney plus
it's gonna be star wars series that's
set during the final days of that same
period and the showrunner the acolyte is
uh uh leslie headland who created
russian doll on netflix um
and uh it sounds like amanda stenberg
may be the lead role of the acolyte i am
super super pumped to act like the show
that we're talking about with john watts
it sounds like it's not going to be the
acolyte it's going to be a different
show so what do you think this story
might be tommy we're talking uh
potentially a hundred years even before
the the prequels
it's gonna say you know this is an era
of star wars that i have a bit of a
blind spot in so i don't i mean younger
generation of heroes during the high
republic era
i don't know i i feel like it's an
opportunity to not be jedi driven you
know what i mean i feel like it's
something to maybe be more of the
you know kind of young military
expectation you know like young military
commitment like who who were who were
becoming the the pilots in the high
republic era you know who who was who
was maybe maybe it's uh in the in the
it's more of a like uh
top gun you know type like fighting out
i mean i know we did we were supposed to
get an x-wing show right wasn't that
originally promised yes uh
patty jenkins is doing rogue squadron
movie that just got pushed to who knows
when and there's gonna be rangers of the
new republic the cara dunes spin-off
that uh i think has been discontinued it
has been discontinued due to poor
comments on instagram uh
i uh
yeah i don't know eric i got to be
honest with you i would love for this to
be if this is a more like not that
strange stranger things is certainly not
a i think stranger things one of the
things that people that don't watch it
confuse it for is they think it's a
kid's show and it is most definitely not
a children's show it's a show featuring
child actors that deals with like murder
and you know
is a pretty scary scary thing i would
love if it was a group of young
uh you know children in the high
republic dealing with like a like
dangerous aliens and nefarious forces
you know against a group of adults that
are kind of like oh come on that's a
legend that's a myth maybe you know
maybe it's a sit maybe they've maybe
they're being taunted by like a sith
lord who's like
you know chasing them around and like
like see us a threat in one of them or
something like that you know maybe it is
just a direct one-to-one stranger things
rip off but not ripoff or true we'll say
tribute yeah it's so hard to know what
they mean by stranger things set in the
star wars universe are they are they
referring to the
the goonies e.t aspect of stranger
things are they referring to uh 11
discovering her powers like that to me
is kind of it like i want to see the
jedi as like the bad guys in the early
days where they're going around just
like recruiting kids into their car just
taking children maybe
yeah you just see like some outer rim
world where just like kids are like uh
some jedi is like a runaway you know
some young padawan gets away from the
jedi forces and comes back and she's
like whoa these people are crazy they
are nuts they don't let you have
attachment to anything
yeah right right so imagine there's like
an 11 type figure who has these powers
uh who has to escape from that cult and
and rediscover friendship and connection
to me that sounds like a fun area to
explore yeah and that sounds like
something john watts would pick up on
you know like he did a pretty good job
of capturing peter parker's like
struggling with the cult of like fame
and personality as spider-man and like
you know even just the little things in
the last movie where it was like the
most famous person on earth and i'm
still broke or something like you know
lines like that like everybody has a
good understanding of of like the high
high stakes or high expectations versus
the the true reality of someone so yeah
yeah i and i think like you know when i
hear this i'm like i'd love to see more
the history of the mandalorian jedi war
i i don't need i don't know if we need
to see more t-visor helmets you know in
live-action we already have plenty of
that going on mandalorian we have our
favorite person who's that um but i i
just wonder if like yeah there is this
era where we we can explore back in the
acolyte era um
and uh you know there was that one line
in boba fett where danny trejo mentioned
the witches of dathomir um and i i want
that to be explored on the acolyte i
think that could be a great place where
the acolyte um is is grounded you know
uh the the planet dathomir the rancor
herders all of those witches uh but if
not that show maybe this could be where
this new john watts series is set in you
know i think we do need to explore some
of this old legends
uh material as star wars canon and that
would be where i want to see next
absolutely time to make it mainstream
baby yeah but i mean shooting this
summer we're gonna learn what the title
of this series is very soon if it's
shooting this summer yeah no kidding um
yeah so that's very very exciting uh
well uh we'll tell you more about it as
we learn more about it and in the weeks
ahead i mean we got a long time
hopefully we'll have an obi-wan kenobi
trailer soon and then we'll we'll spend
these weeks ahead talking about that and
everything new we learned about star
wars you can find us every week here on
new rockstars on wikileaks so follow me
at ea boss follow tommy at tommybechtold
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcasts
thanks for watching and goodbye bye then
it's so stupid i love it
[Music]
you